Генеральний секретар НАТО Єнс Столтенберг
з трибуни Верховної Ради, цитуючи Тараса Шевченка,
закликав українських політиків разом працювати
на благо всіх українців.
"Страшно впасти у кайдани,
умирать в неволі,
а ще гірше – спати, спати
і спати на волі…"
- Воля - це не лише право, а й обов'язок діяти
не просто у своїх власних інтересах, а в найкращих
інтересах усього народу.
Однак не встиг генсек НАТО прибути до України, як
у Києві вкотре засперечалися про ПДЧ -
План дій щодо членства в НАТО.
Сум'яття посіяв Петро Порошенко, який з трибуни
парламенту закинув Володимиру Зеленському, що
той добровільно відмовився від подання заявки щодо ПДЧ.
- Добровільна відмова від ПДЧ
виглядає як самозречення перспективи,
як небажання дратувати Путіна. Як страх
брати на себе відповідальність за реалізацію
надзвичайно складного питання.
У відповідь президент Володимир Зеленський запевнив:
- Ми готові ще тісніше співпрацювати з Альянсом
і прискорити підготовку до членства в НАТО,
не знімаючи з порядку денного можливість
приєднання України до Плану дій щодо членства в НАТО,
ми готові вже сьогодні практичною роботою доводити:
Україна заслуговує такого формату відносин з Альянсом.
То який статус-кво нині в відносинах України та НАТО?
Заявку щодо ПДЧ Україна офіційно подала в НАТО
ще в січні 2008 року, тобто
ще за президентства Віктора Ющенка.
У квітні того ж року на Бухарестському саміті НАТО
Альянс привітав євроатлантичні прагнення Києва,
але люб'язно відмовив Києву.
Тепер, через 11 років після дипломатичної поразки
України в Бухаресті, п’ятий президент України Петро Порошенко
виступає за те, щоб Київ знову попросив у НАТО ПДЧ.
Разом із тим сам Порошенко за 5 років
свого президентства хоча й намагався зрушити
тему вступу в НАТО з мертвого місця,
жодних заявок не подавав.
Нинішня влада не бачить підстав
для повторного подання. Аргументи такі:
по-перше, поки немає передумов для подачі
нової заявки на ПДЧ, оскільки Україна ще
не виконала "домашні завдання" Альянсу, зокрема
щодо переходу на стандарти НАТО. По-друге,
з точки зору безпеки - на тлі війни на Донбасі та анексії Криму -
нині в Україні значно гірша ситуація, ніж була у 2008,
а це зменшує шанси на отримання ПДЧ. Окрім того,
Угорщина через конфлікт із офіційним Києвом
щодо закону про освіту та угорські паспорти
для українців намагається блокувати засідання
комісії Україна-НАТО. За таких умов, вважає МЗС України,
шансів отримати ПДЧ в НАТО наразі немає,
тому пропонують інше.
У новому уряді пропонують зосередитися
на внутрішніх реформах і запровадженні тих
стандартів НАТО, які дозволять Україні досягти
сумісності Збройних сил України з арміями членів НАТО,
зокрема визначити першочергові стандарти,
шляхи досягнення цих стандартів, а також
механізм спільної оцінки їхнього впровадження.
В уряді також нарікають, що нині між Україною та НАТО
існує дуже багато програм і проектів,
ефективність яких відстежити дуже важко.
Тому планують об'єднати всі аспекти співпраці
в один комплексний документ. Також хочуть
створити систему незалежного моніторингу
виконання Річної національної програми під егідою
комісії Україна-НАТО.
Невиконаних "домашніх завдань" ще багато.
Як підсумував генсек НАТО в Верховній Раді:
- Двері Альянсу відчинені, але шлях до членства в НАТО складний.
Українці, судячи з усього, цього бажають.
За соцопитуванням Центру стратегічного розвитку,
проведеним у липні цього року,
вступ України до НАТО підтримують 62% українців.
Кожен другий громадянин України вважає членство
в Альянсі основною гарантією нацбезпеки України.